and it looked like at least one  potentially two or more shooters in the  shopping center started certainly in a  McDonald's fast-food restaurant shooting  people and then we don't really know  what happened thereafter except there  were reports that 15 people had been  shot the latest we have from the  Bavarian interior ministry is that three  people are dead and a number of others  are injured as we look at these pictures  now you can see that there are  effectively several strands of emergency  service response we see on the right of  the screen armed and wearing body armor  police presumably moving closer to the  scene and we've also seen lots of also  armed but with no body armor presumably  moving the other way police escorting  people from the area and potentially  from the shopping center itself